let's create an old film effect in After
Effects the first thing I want to do is
give the footage that old school shake
so I'm going to select key for position
right click separate dimensions and on
the Y position I'm going to control or
alt click to add an expression I type in
wiggle parentheses 24 comma 6
parentheses which means 24 times per
second the Y Position will fluctuate by
6 pixels next we're going to add an
adjustment layer and I'm going to add
three effects to it in the curves effect
I'm going to add three points to create
a curve that brings up the shadows and
brings down the highlights and the Hue
and saturation effect I'm going to drop
the saturation by about 25 and in the
camera lens blur effect I'm going to
alter option click on the blur radius
and type in wiggle parentheses 6 comma
10 parentheses and there you have it an
Ultima effect created entirely in After
Effects
foreign